[Music]  on the second anniversary of the January  6 Capital Riot the two men arrested here  in Las Vegas for their roles have since  pleaded guilty the FBI arrested Nate  degrave and Ronnie Sandlin at an  apartment near the strip just weeks  after the Insurrection both have since  taken plea deals a judge has yet however  to sentence to grave Sandlin will serve  several years in prison he spoke  exclusively with our eight news now  investigators about that day  there's going to be  properly you know Give me liberty or  give me death we got caught up at the  moment we got caught up in a mob  mentality  the January 6 committee found while some  were publicly spouting accusations of  massive fraud privately they admitted  there was none at least seven people  died in connection with the riot that  day